daran können sie sich noch erinnern im
märz in dortmund der kampf von felix
sturm und fett comedy kommt und
knallt oliver pocher eine vor allen
zuschauern ja und oliver pocher der hat
jetzt ich würde sagen gestrichen die
schnauze voll er geht nicht nur gegen
die ohrfeige vor er will das fett comedy
richtig sein fett weg bekommt und ja
zieht sich die justiz bandagen an er
will ihm nämlich den mund verbieten
lassen also ring frei für eine neue
runde
red comedy im knast schlafzimmer und
badezimmer in einem gemeinsamen raum der
blick nach draußen eingeschränkt durch
schwedische gardinen doch dieses video
ist nicht ernst sondern ein social media
geht vom selbsternannten retter und
komiker in dem er den streit mit oliver
pocher verhöhnt schon wieder
genug für pocher selbst schluss mit
lustig machen nach monatelangen
verbalattacken und der öffentlichen
ohrfeige von fett comedy kommt die
nächste justiz attacke des lagers die
hat es in sich mit einer mehrseitigen
unterlassungserklärung will oliver
pocher steht comedy verbieten sich
weiter über ihn lustig zu machen und den
fall über die sozialen medien
auszuschlachten
26 märz die mega boxnacht felix sturm
gegen istvan cilli in dortmund doch an
diesem abend findet der kampf nicht nur
im ring statt fett comedy holt aus und
schlägt zuschauer oliver pocher mit ins
gesicht der geht zu boden rettet sich
vor der brutalen attacke das video des
feigen angriff postet der möchtegern
rapper fed comedy danach bei social
media es verbreitet sich wie ein
lauffeuer sorgt deutschlandweit für
schlagzeilen fett comedy 23 jahre alt
bürgerlich giovanni zum rhein
rechtfertigt seine ohrfeige damals so
aber wie gesagt ich habe mich in dem
moment einfach von meinen emotionen
leiten lassen wenige tage später äußert
sich oliver pocher erstmals in einem
langen instagram video zu der feigen
attacke droht mit ernsthaften
konsequenzen führt comedy und es werden
wir vom gericht und mit allen mitteln in
der nächsten zeit kann und ich hoffe auf
eine maximale strafe auch mit
abschreckender wirkung doch fett comedy
zeigt sich unbeeindruckt schamlos
provoziert der 23 jährige oliver pocher
bei social media macht sich in videos
und fotos über die brutale ohrfeige
lustig
[Musik]
der komiker postet fotos einer flachen
hand in seiner instagram story schreibt
dazu kam ist deine hand fällt comedy
startet sogar einen spendenaufruf für
oliver pocher sogar das ermitteln der
dortmunder staatsanwaltschaft wegen
vorsätzlicher körperverletzung gegen den
komiker hält fed kommen die nicht ab
postet diese schamlose video aus einem
gefängnis in welchem er gerade ein
musikvideo dreht die provokation an
oliver pocher mehr als eindeutig an fett
comedys vermeintlicher zelle hängen
fotos von seiner brutalen ohrfeige sogar
bilder von oliver pochers frau am irak
im bikini außerdem veröffentlicht der
möchtegern rapper ein weiteres video aus
dem gefängnis
für oliver genug liegt die harten
bandagen der justiz anfällt comedy zeigt
sich unbeeindruckt der genießt momentan
urlaub in der sonne und äußert sich bei
bild exklusiv so
das gefühl kann man aber nicht
einstellen
keine einsicht bei fett comedy keine
gnade von oliver pocher dieser kampf ist
somit noch lange nicht vorbei ring frei
für die nächste runde
[Musik]
handtaschen oder nein überhaupt nicht
lustig und man muss ja immer wieder
sagen es ist mir auch ganz wichtig das
feld kommen sie da getan hat das geht
einfach nicht gewalt ist nie eine lösung
das war eine hinterhältige attacke und
ich würde da genauso wenig spaß
verstehen ich verstehe auch oliver
pocher nun muss man natürlich sagen
oliver pocher ist jemand der sich
natürlich schon auch über andere
menschen aus lässt und der eigentlich
immer gesagt hat verbal ist viel in
ordnung wenn es dann körperlich wird
nicht mehr aber jetzt findet er die ja
die verbalen attacken und dass sie über
sich möglich man halt auch nicht mehr
weh aber ich will vor allem aber auch
die sozusagen diese
drogen oder was gegen seine frau dir
damit ist das ist völlig das ist völlig
daneben und dagegen muss man sich auch
wehren und das ist so ein bisschen so
man wisse nicht dass es auch ein
schlechtes vorbild führt zum beispiel
junge menschen also es gibt immer wieder
auseinandersetzungen auch auf schulhöfen
dann verprügelt da ein junge einen
anderen oder ein mädchen untereinander
und dann wird das dann wird das auch
noch ins netz gestellt und sich dann
andere machen sich darüber lustig das
geht einfach nicht